[موسيقى]
كنا مجموعة من الشباب ونحن
حاولنا الذهاب إلى سجن الباستيل هناك
أدركنا أن كل الشوارع
كانت مسدودة
تمكنا من الوصول
سوق شوارع المتظاهرين
لذلك كانت على يساري في بداية
المظاهرة
وفي المقابل كان هناك رجال الشرطة
كانت خوذة ركل قد اشتعلت
وقت تقدموا شرقا
وبلا أعرف أمرًا
لا أعرف أي واحد لا يعرفونه
بدأ الضرب بالهراوات يذكرني
قد سقط لتلقي ضربة في اثنين
وسعادة كبيرة
رجل في دمشق يقبض على ماتيوس وهو
قال لي آه عشرين سنة صغيرة وهناك
كان لديها نساء بيض كبيرات
قد يستغرق ثلاثة أمتار من
في المرمى يمكن ورمينا له
لوحات أتذكر بياضا
سقطت علي لكنها مرت فوق
من الرأس كان له كابون له
القبعات الكولا الذي أخذها ليست كذلك
لحسن الحظ رأسي
[موسيقى]
حاولنا خنق فعل ذلك من أجل
أسباب سياسية كانت التعليمات
لفترات طويلة لشهور
سنوات على الرغم من جهود الدفاع
و
انتهى بالفصل لمدة شهر
بعد تدخل قانون فقدان الذاكرة
من الواضح أن denisty كان إنهاء
إمكانية إجراءات البحث
[موسيقى]
رأينا رجال شرطة يدعون
المتظاهرين من قبل الساقين
الأقدام والكتفين التي
تأرجح هكذا ورميها
فوق شبكة المترو
[موسيقى]